so the uh Amber Heard Johnny Depp trial
has been going everybody's been tuning
in like crazy yeah of course about today
is Johnny Depp Amber Heard and the
defamation tribe on today's show I want
to talk about the conversation and
debate happening about the public
consumption of this trial we're starting
to see a lot of criticism regarding the
the way this has kind of turned into a
meme machine though there's also been
push back there so let's try and talk it
out so to start there is literally no
way to overstate the public interest in
this trial because based on social media
interactions America is reportedly more
interested in this case than things like
abortion rights in the war in Ukraine
yeah remember what I said about the Will
Smith slap oh yeah people are dying you
crank but Will Smith slapped Chris Rock
that's a bigger story nobody cares
nobody cares nobody's apparently even
trying to sell black market access to
the courtroom so that's led to a lot of
people questioning why people are so
excited even reveling in a case that
deals with domestic abuse allegations
because a lot of the content that's out
there it's not like the the stuff that
Emily D Baker or a number of people are
doing like a lot of the content is jokes
making fun of it specifically I've heard
the places like Rolling Stone noting
that one audio of heard a legend the
depth hitter is very popular online with
people spoofing it putting cats and wigs
over it people in the comments heating
it up and while there are a lot of
different types of content if you look
online it's not surprising that a lot of
these Jabs are specifically aimed at
Amber Heard because just a quick Twitter
search shows you that way more people
appear to be on depth side right now but
as the trial has continued on we have
more people going is it okay to joke
about this with people arguing that it
doesn't matter who you side with in the
situation you still shouldn't turn this
case into clickbait comedy with a piece
in the guardian saying regardless of
whether an individual believes herd's
testimony they should believe that
nothing good can come from minimizing
and mocking descriptions of abuse the
trial has made it clearer than ever that
a culture of toxic fandom has poisoned
our brain you you this is that whole
like uh oh you can't make fun of this
this is unacceptable that's coming up
again
replace the word for uh you know
domestic uh boo-boos and
appreciate that
[Music]
there you go
and you go
yeah you go laughing about the Mythic
movie again
you shouldn't be laughing about domestic
boo-boos
should be laughing about the best of
boo-boos that's a domestic boo-boo
victim
you're laughing about the Mystic boo-boo
victims I'm sorry that was so unintendo
why why are you laughing about
monetization if you use that certain
word they lose their minds I was like
what work can I use and the only one
that came to mind
I think it works well
okay hashtag boo-boos too
I was boo-booed as well
um
I was
no okay but just replace that word okay
and you could put in most things you
could put murder okay you could put
um knife crime but the truth is we allow
people to make jokes about murders all
the time people's deaths all the time we
allow all of these jokes but this is one
topic where everyone says no you can't
and if you ask them for a logical reason
as to why we can joke about other things
but not this specifically they'll just
be like God well it contributes to a
culture of like and you can say that
about pretty much any joke technically
speaking if you were to use that
argument me personally I think you
should be able to joke about whatever it
was people say no no you can't do a joke
about this or that it's like why
not I'll joke about it
I'm not saying you have to laugh I'm not
saying you have to love it but saying
people shouldn't or can't because it
could you if you don't want to joke
about it don't damn that's it nothing
good can come from minimizing plenty of
good people can laugh people can derive
some Joy that's good right there might
not be good or joy for you but it is for
other people so when you say why would
anyone who does that it's like so so if
someone was a boo-boo victim
and they they talk about their boo boo
story
I'm trying to move away from that nope
I'm not moving away all right not going
down this Rabbit Hole oh yep
oh my God so if there's a booboo victim
and he's thought that the victim's
talking about their Boo Boo as a therapy
you know the counter the boo boo
can't talk about that boo boo they can't
they can't laugh about the boo-boo they
can't you know you can laugh about your
own boo-boos but you can't laugh about
others all right let's move on let's
just put this [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't know
why he's doing this the thing is it's
not completely black and white right
there are those that believe Johnny Depp
it's not completely black and white
right there are those that believe
Johnny Depp they they don't believe
Amber Heard but they're still afraid of
what consequences could be from all of
this with a number of them hitting on a
note that USA Today hit on saying the
loudest voices on the internet may not
believe heard but millions of women have
had experiences like the ones she
describes when people mock her experts
say they're inadvertently laughing at
every person who has said they are a
victim of abuse you know how many you
know how many victims of this
well watch this whole thing and go no
we're laughing because she's a [ __ ]
liar and her story is ridiculous
everybody's looking at this at this
story and they see the overwhelming
evidence they've heard the voice
recordings from Amber herself saying
that she was attacking Johnny doing all
this stuff and they see her lying on the
stand right and getting caught in lives
and they're like well yeah this is
hilarious this is like a joke of a story
this one that everybody ate up and oh my
God I didn't hear the same energy okay
when she first came out with her story
in the entire media system jumped behind
her and protected her yeah now that
she's being exposed used as a liar
they're trying to make into a bigger
problem like well there are other women
who may be affected by the fact that if
you'd have done your job at the [ __ ]
beginning and called out the
inconsistencies in their stories and
listened to all the recordings before
you did your [ __ ] reporting and your
fluff pieces to prop her up maybe this
wouldn't be a big deal today the reason
why people take so much of an interest
is because they see something being
unjust to somebody and they've seen it
on a public platform and these are Mega
stars and so they're like yo this is
clearly unjust that's why people are
interested that's why people are
laughing about it discussing it
seriously doing all these things do your
job and then maybe it won't get to this
point but anyways actually people could
actually argue that you are the one
minimizing what she did because you want
to kind of protect her you kind of want
to uh no but you know we shouldn't
laughing no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no we're laughing no we're
laughing at this because that person was
caught being a liar we're laughing and
us not laughing at that is minimizing
what she's supposed to go through as a
liar as someone that that has a
perpetrators yeah and so so you're the
one that's only minimizing no we
shouldn't laugh at this we're not
laughing at Johnny
we're laughing at someone that claims to
be a hero and poops in the bed
who does that I'm laughing if you poop
the bed
intentionally
unintentionally I'm if you poop in the
bed I'm laughing okay okay that's facts
I don't I just think it's so funny that
they think that us laughing and mocking
this stuff is is harmful I don't know
it's just crazy to me that you guys
probably somebody who's engaging in the
very Behavior but you got something to
say about folks who are laughing about
her ridiculous lies seems a little weird
like the priorities don't make any
[ __ ] sense to me
and understand this is not me trying to
tell you who to believe or not believe
this person's on the right this is the
person that's wrong this is solely about
the constant mockery and entertainment
aspect of this trial well this has been
a rampant thing since pretty much the
beginning I feel like a lot of attention
on this debate started because of SNL
they parodied the trial with the judge
and that's good even saying this trial
is for fun and that resulted in a ton of
headlines and just not sitting right
with a lot of people people saying
things like domestic violence is not a
joke is not a joke abusers using the
legal system to continue to terrorize
their victims is not a joke abusers
using accusations of defame you making
this tweet which basically infers that
Johnny's the one in the wrong this oh
that's acceptable
with your own little [ __ ] you just
boom he's guilty that and that is
actually more harmful though the jokes
that are being made about any of this
stop yay now we're gonna laugh about it
I think we should do a full six minutes
where we just crack jokes about this
whole case yeah yeah just just be Petty
yeah I can all suck a fat one starts
with boo-boo yeah this whole this whole
Mantra like just condemning dudes with
zero to little no evidence that's not
harmful you guys never had any energy
for that oh they made a joke
They're laughing oh that's harmful yeah
not the people you put behind bars not
the people's reputations and lives you
ruined not that last jobs or whatever
the jokes are the problem the jokes get
the [ __ ] out of here please get the [ __ ]
out of here defamations to silence their
victims is not a joke in 20 years people
are going to look back at this trial and
all of the media coverage and be
disgusted as well as you're free to have
absolutely no opinion on the deaf herd
trial but thinking it's for fun is for
someone with a diseased heart and brain
with that we've seen instances pop up
where you have a hey shout out to you
all for protecting this woman what did
this Pokemon
really mean corporate needs you to find
the difference between this this picture
and this picture they're the same
picture
tenses pop up or you have a big creators
like Pokemon even deleting a tweet after
facing backlash or posting a meme about
the trial people saying put it back
put it back Pokemon put it back put it
back I believe that we are in the era uh
that I call the era of Niche okay
everything is Niche you're trying to
make everything mainstream if a thing is
not for you then it's not mainstream
it's not for you it's not your niche
just don't look at it don't listen to it
turn it off I don't want it out there
you don't want to look at it then don't
look at it it will happen that's the era
of Niche everybody could do their own
little thing I don't agree to it I don't
watch it or something Apple TV that I
don't watch because I all like it
there's certain things that I don't
really watch I don't want they could do
whatever the hell they want
I could critique it but I leave it alone
they have the right to do that right
shut up
shut up yup this is the era that we live
living where you don't have to put every
everything on a mainstream and still
make a revenue out of that yeah Niche
the era of me that's what it is all
right listen Tick Tock is normally
cringe I'm glad they're making fun of
her though
I'll just say that they're they're a
they're having a field trip oh are they
oh
get on the school bus I mean this trial
is a big one yes yeah if you guys want
to see us cover more of this Amber Heard
there's a Johnny Depp stuff let us know
in the comments below we want to hear
from you